thaddeus is with us thaddeus is
in fayetteville north carolina hi
thaddeus how are you
uh pretty good how about yourself better
than i deserve what's up
so uh it's kind of silly because the the
last caller
had a similar situation i'm having car
issues
i'm right at the beginning of of the
program i've listened for a long time
but i just started to really
really want to get into it cool and the
issue i have is that
my fiance and i we share a car it's
very high mileage it has mechanical
issues it's not
highway safe i've already put probably
the value of the car in trying to get
the car fixed and
you know i'm still having these issues
um so we're working on baby step one now
identifying our debts and um getting the
thousand dollar emergency funds and what
i heard in the last caller was in
between step one and two we should be
looking for
you know another vehicle to supplement
this one yeah
so my concern now and get rid of that
and get rid of that one because it's
killing you right
so you're driving a thousand dollar car
you might as well drive a reliable
thousand dollar car
exactly exactly um so
where my concern is now is i drive a lot
from from work
um at least 10 to 15 hours a week
um and i'm concerned that if i get into
another
thousand dollar vehicle that i'm gonna
have all these same problems again where
it just kind of turns into a money pit
and we just constantly feel like we're
spinning our wheels and not getting
ahead
yeah well here's the thing here's the
thing okay you don't have a choice you
don't have any money
yes sir and you're not gonna do it
forever what do you make
so i recently my income is variable and
it's
going up so it's kind of difficult for
me to say what i make
what do you think you're gonna make next
month uh next month
um five to six thousand wow that's
pretty good
it is pretty good i mean you you know
like four months ago you weren't making
hardly that right
oh four months ago i was making like 15.
yeah
okay so that's a lot of money you got a
lot of spare change right now
you gotta buy a thousand dollar car out
of that one month
yeah if it doesn't work buy another one
the next month
yeah yes sir um it's difficult for me to
budget because i'm paid in arrears 30 to
45 days
um and um and my paychecks vary you know
i'll get a paycheck for a few thousand
dollars so i'll get one that's like
barely a thousand depending on
how the payments are processed um so i'm
having
but if you're gonna make five thousand
dollars in a month regardless of when
the payments come or when the
checks come you're going to have five
thousand dollars in a 30-day period of
time agreed
correct so when you get the money buy a
car
okay okay and pay cash for it you know
pay cash for it buy you a fifteen
hundred two thousand dollar car
and then if you uh and then start saving
to where
you know after christmas maybe january
maybe you buy a five thousand dollar car
that you saved up for the difference and
weave that into
because you need to get up out of the
junk i agree with you on that these
junky cars will kill you okay i don't
want you driving a 1500
car for five years i don't even want you
driving it for one year
but if you have to for a little while
you can and if you'll buy
wisely on a 1500 2000 car you can get a
year out of it
agreed agreed i mean just an old honda
that looks like crap but is really
mechanically
in good condition old toyota camry right
an old taurus
they got a lot of life in those cars
they're ugly as crud some of them
but that doesn't matter we're not trying
to buy something to attract a girl you
already have a fiance
yeah yeah yeah i don't have anyone to
impress i just
want to uh want to and by the way
by the way you and your fiance don't
need to own anything together until
you're married
yes sir that's going that's going to
cause problems
so uh but but when are you getting
married
um we just got engaged and with the
whole corona thing
it's like kind of up in the air i'm of
the mind that i just want to go to the
courthouse and get it done and then we
can do the family thing later
yeah but um i don't know how she really
feels about she's trepidatious about
that you know yeah well our call call
what's going on the preacher and go over
and sit down with them and you know get
married this weekend and then
later on we can do all the celebration
stuff because i'm guessing if you guys
were to combine your resources and
combine your dreams
they'd probably be more efficient for
you not only relationally but
financially as well and so that would
always be my recommendation in these
situations
because i can tell you're playing house
anyway you might as well be married
so that's the thing painter get off the
ladder dude